Civil years now since a crime this is
the greatest moment Brooke I you've made
my [ __ ] life hey everybody this is
gary vay-ner-chuk and this episode 295
of the askgaryvee show and this is like
you know what I love about life timing
this is somebody that I have an enormous
amount of admiration to we're gonna go
into it we're gonna do phone calls cuz I
think a lot of people want access to
this dude he's out and about but getting
access to him is very difficult cuz he's
busy so we're gonna do phone calls
Facebook putting your phone numbers Andy
is here and he's gonna pick some calls
we'll do that towards the end we're live
how should I put this of my social media
I'm doing this you could do whatever the
[ __ ] you want you're good we you know
unlike normal things that you do we have
enough social media power to get you
exposed you usually people are asking
you because you have so much power but
you can't but that's not the what we
need to do what we need to do is get
some phone numbers from Facebook for the
show Scooter Braun is in the building
this is you know I am I have
contemporaries people that are 10 years
younger and older I would say in the way
that I use contemporaries that I really
admire scooters really genuinely one of
those five or six people at the top of
the list not only for his ridiculousness
in accomplishing things that I admire
which is business comma culture comma
the most important part just a good
human being we've had a we had a pretty
funny text exchange maybe three or four
months ago just on that of like rooting
for you rooting for you like not a lot
of people with the kind of parenting and
DNA that we have families there's just
so much I can go into his brother is one
of my dear friends I said I sit on the
board of pencils of promise and been
involved with that but when we met for
the first time ever eight or nine years
ago we're waiting outside of Nobu in
Midtown they're not ready to seat us
we're just meeting my brother AJ's there
which was rare for me to bring my
brother to a meeting back in a day but
the reason was cuz scooter and his
brother
were there we're just getting to know
each other we kind of be put in touch by
CAA or somebody else we're just getting
to know each other the first thing we
get into in 30 seconds is our deep love
with New York Jets and within 19 seconds
of that Mark Sanchez our starting
quarterback walks by us not a but
neither of us know Matt the time and
we're like that just happened then we
get seated next to them it becomes this
whole classic story and thus becomes a
great friendship and watching what you
know at that point you were managing
Justin so you'd already kind of
quote-unquote made it into the
consciousness but nowhere to the Mogul
impact you're making now I'm really glad
you're here scooter thanks for thanks
buddy
yeah another narration is mutual so
thanks I uh I've watched you do these
from a distance we've joked around about
you know me actually coming here and
finding the time and you know I'm
excited for this one because I don't
think I'll ever yell back and forth on a
pod the way we're probably about to go
to your point we've been talking about
doing this for quite a while you know
scooters cool and what that means is
that he face times not calls or texts
yeah right he's in the culture which I
also like to FaceTime people to make
them feel uncomfortable a hundred
percent you have to you have to like
stuff it's the best weekends but what's
most fun is that scooter and I activate
our friendship the most during football
season were both I heard jet fans and
the fact that out of all the times we
could have possibly done this it's we're
doing it literally the Monday after a
third loss in a row you know the Rose is
super off the bloom on this one next
year on the chain what was the last
thing I texted on the channel because
we're in a chain with like a bunch of
Jets fan and the last thing I texted it
was this is not fun it's just not and so
sort of real quick for the you know
knowing my audience for the three to six
percent because that's how little it is
that don't know anything about you give
me the comic book number one origin
story because I think there's there's so
many things I admire about your origin
story I'll bring them up if you don't
get to them but what is the three-minute
version of who you are in your words um
look I was a kid who who grew up with
two amazing parents my dad was a refugee
from Hungary who actually grew up in
Queens my mom grew up in the
skill mountains and she lost her died
when she was 11 and really you know made
you know her own accomplishments after
that and they moved us to a suburb of
New York and I grew up with you know
amazing siblings I have there's five of
us when I was a teenager my parents
adopted two more so they became five of
us and I was kind of a kid who played
ball like I played basketball growing up
and I thought that's you know what I was
gonna do is gonna coach or maybe become
a lawyer who knows I knew I was going to
the NBA five foot eleven jus just it
wasn't adding up but when I got to
college I kind of became frustrated with
being broke so you know I started first
selling fake IDs and then quickly
realized I was gonna get caught so I
stopped doing that I became a party
promoter and became a very big party
promoter in Atlanta Georgia at the
height of hip hop growing in Atlanta in
like 2000 yes some of your throwback
Thursday photos are so gangster they
just are there it's funny like Young
Jeezy and I knew each other when he was
just Young Jeezy the drug dealer right
and he would come to my parties and we
would hang out but you know I kind of
came up I worked
throw them bows for Ludacris that was
the first person I worked in the club's
this guy Shakir Stewart put me in the
music game with Shaka Zulu little
Chris's manager and then Jermaine Dupri
asked me to help him out I was 20 years
old became the vice president and a So
So Def dropped out of school young
bloods you know I didn't know that you
dropped out of school dropped out of
school my parents [ __ ] so for the first
semester of me being dropped out I you
lied well I lied I actually paid for the
semester so they send my parents the
mail mm-hmm and by them getting the mail
they didn't really know I was in school
and then they kept asking me stories and
I'd always be traveling cuz I was using
at the time Air Tran which was this
airline I went under who's out of
Atlanta they had something didn't go
under because a plane crashed I don't
even know why I remember Air Tran well
they shout out to moose my homie who was
my boy lived in Alpharetta after college
in Iran
dude we would go to Vegas for a weekend
and like he'd get there for $4 well this
is the thing and he was at a college ID
just cuz this is pre 9/11 so wasn't even
ID it was just a college ID go anywhere
an Air Tran if there was an available
seat for 49 bucks
that's what he did and I would fly all
around the country working building
relationships for $49 a ticket and I
would throw my parties and then you know
throw parties a Miami in here and I was
traveling all around the country on Air
Tran $49 and that gave me an opportunity
to get places when you were throwing
parties I'm just me now getting fun and
excited and curious on the there's only
two deltas on the Delta business and on
the Delta of like hooking up and having
fun
what were you at that point when your
business 100/100 I kind of thought
that's what you're gonna say that's why
I asked yeah I was a hundred actually
fully believe that yeah I was a hundred
percent my thing was did I have fun was
I single did I meet girls yes but never
the ones at my parties if I was gonna
meet women
it was on the days where I was in
throwing parties and I was going out if
you were coming to my parties I wasn't
you were working I was working and I
wasn't getting caught up I didn't even
drink maybe I'd do a shot here and there
but I was there to make money and run a
business and I had no interest and I
always used to say the guys were trying
to get laid off of being a party
promoter they're gonna lose to me
because they're too busy they're too
busy focusing on the wrong thing that's
right
and we built a massive party business we
were the highest college promotion
company in the country revenue wise and
we expanded all over the place and then
started helping Jermaine doing all that
and then when I was 24 I had all these
ideas about social media because
Facebook could come and you know I I had
all these ideas and Jermaine wasn't
really listening to me on them um and I
got great advice for my dad where he
said look as long as you work for
someone else you can give your ideas but
it's their company if you want to go for
it go for it and then Little John was
could you just produce yeah for uh sure
he and I were out together and he said
look I worked for Jermaine for seven
years as an A&R don't take seven years
he's a great guy but you got to go after
your own and long story but I ended up
leaving not by choice actually we'll get
into that later interesting but it was
it was more me wanting to leave and not
doing it because I was afraid again in
the universe corrected that for me how
something happened in the office where
you know basically me and Jermaine's mom
got into it on some stupid yep and the
next day I come in and she had fired me
and yeah I mean it's like well just give
it two weeks and I'll fix it and that
was enough for me to be like this is not
the career that I want and she gave me
the out and now I got to go for it
and I started my own management and
record label signed a kid off myspace
named Asher Roth and we had a big record
call I lost this uh yeah this weekend a
49ers fan Davis Anderson and four months
after that I was online middle of the
night looking at little boys sing cuz
that's what that's what how you find
success you go on the Internet in the
middle of the night and watch little
boys singing don't do that that's a joke
huh but you know what's interesting to
me and I don't know where I picked this
up through our travels through the years
but there was a part of you you know
it's funny and I think of Troy Cardin
things that nature like I'm so fat like
there was definitely a part of you that
was strategic of like you know the
hip-hop industry has a lot of
vulnerabilities on the talent and just a
million different things and just raw
numbers of how many albums sell like you
weren't just doing that for kicks and
giggles there was a thought process of a
pop star and you also do this right I
don't know I remember this vividly from
literally I think our first dinner like
a decade ago didn't you try to put
together a boyband like wouldn't at some
point as well well I I tried I try to
find holes in the marketplace and what I
did was try not a boy band I put
together a group and it'll be your house
yeah they lived in my house they ended
up robbing the apartment complex that I
put them in and it was like you know it
was like I tried a couple different
things I put together another group and
then they actually went to jail for bank
robbery that I didn't know they were
robbing federal banks like that's a real
thing I got investigated by the FBI like
it was pretty wild but did all those
experience take you to like I need like
a nine-year-old child what they took me
to was someone saying you're trying to
sign everything that you think we want
instead of what you want interesting and
you know this guy Jerry smoke and B who
at the time was the program director of
hot 97 Atlanta he said you're really
talented stop trying to sign everything
that you think we want sign what you
want and what you think is good and I
looked in the marketplace and I said
what's the opening and with Asher I was
like you know the time Eminem was the
only white rapper and I said here's this
kid who can really spit but also isn't
trying to be anything he isn't and
there's a lot of kids who go to hip-hop
shows who look like him and relate to
him and that's why I did dance and with
Justin I was said to college song he did
he did and with Justin uh you know I
looked at it and I said one Chaka Zulu
said you Ludacris his manager he said
you're lucky if you
one big star your whole career one
breakthrough people can live off that
forever I said well I'm gonna break two
right away if that's the case and with
just and I said I'm a big Michael
Jackson fan and Michael used to sing
these angelic love songs in the Jackson
5 and his voice reminded you of you knew
her kid before you were jaded by love so
you believe in the love story and when I
saw Justin I was like this is the kid
I've been looking for and I found him
brought in inside Justin with no
[ __ ] like I'm just dying to know you
may not remember but I'm dying to know
this because I don't know it how many
views was he getting on his new 60,000
about 60,000 yeah which was at the time
a lot but nothing compared to what it
was it was like okay people are paying
attention but you know at the time like
you know people gave a [ __ ] and you if
you had a million but that was a million
was slicing break3 and it was our like
20th video where we got our first a
million but all the videos we had
accumulated up until that suddenly
become anybody use did he have that you
were able to look at for four to six I
think and you emailed him through
YouTube well I tried I tried everything
but his mom had a different last name in
the name and I tried everything and then
I googled the company's in the back of
the image and I found out they were a
part of Ontario and I called every
school board in that part of Ontario
until I found him and then his mom
called to get rid of me she thought I
was a stalker and after 45 minutes of
speaking to me she agreed to get on the
first plane ride either of them had ever
been on and we've been together ever
since I love it it's insane
okay cool so that you were that that's
who that's like your I mean that's the
nuts the origin and then we went on and
things went well and I really focused on
that for four years and then someone who
I respect it took a shot at me and said
oh he's good but he only has that and I
got pissed so I said okay well I'm gonna
sign things that I can very quickly so I
signed you know the wanted with glad you
came I saw in Gangnam style I sign I
remember you know Carly Rae Jepsen would
call me maybe by the way my most fun
story that I scooter doesn't know this I
went over scooters house in LA and just
on a friend visit and I was just there
for a night flying back next morning
texted me said come over I came over and
he's like hey man I want you to listen
to this song and I'm like I don't I'm
not from the new music industry that's
not my norm Boyd and I do some fun stuff
and hip hop these days but like I
this might be the third time in my life
I ever heard a song before anybody else
and he plays call me baby and I'm like
man that's super [ __ ] catchy but like
I thought I was just doing that because
I don't even know but to watch that's
like man that is so fun I did it with
like startups I do it with wine I do
with other things but like music is so
deeply cultural and that was such a
smash hit song like that was the song of
the year to like hear it in your
backyard that night and then like two
months later you know here at every
single place ever that's that's a fun
part of your game mm-hmm no it's Justin
heard her on the radio in Canada what
was I saying Justin heard her on the
radio in Canada's friend told the news
number 36 on the Canadian chart and then
he came back and played and I said this
is really good and I looked into it and
the labels in the US had passed and I
said oh this is not this is so I went
and I signed it for the world wide
outside of Keona
and we ended up selling 26 million
copies or something and uh and then
Gangnam style and then yeah and then and
then and then it was then we signed
Arianna and Martin garrix and you know
we just kept going and then we bought
other management companies and we just
expanded and I'm always in this
mentality you and I've talked about it
that out of everything that's happened
from TV to film all these different
things
I just assume it's gonna end tomorrow at
all time so you're squeezing the [ __ ]
out of it not even squeezing the [ __ ]
out of it just never letting it be
overwhelming in a way of thinking I did
it like I I'm we can argue about this I
actually don't know how you feel about
this I just I just think anyone who says
that luck doesn't play a part in their
success is naive I think it's completely
predicated on how you define luck like
like I think like I think so much is not
in my control and so that's how I think
about it right like luck is an
interesting word I think the way one
uses it but much like the person said
he's good but he's only got one thing to
me I was treated for wheat like I was
born in the Soviet Union during the
height of the Cold War and nobody in my
country let's get it very simple here
nobody in my country had left that
country for 40 years you couldn't leave
they didn't let you leave that's what
the Soviet Union was and I got to leave
as a three
your old baby or just because 400,000
Jews got traded for wheat because Russia
needed some wheat and American Israel
teamed up like to me that is the most
lucky thing but to me it's all depends
on how you look at like most of our
lives are not like you can get hit by
truck tomorrow no 100% but I I look at
it as a fact of like I think if you
acknowledge that look you don't get you
don't lose it
see you know ah you're going and I agree
with you completely it's like getting
high in your own like thinking like
can't get high on your own supply
couldn't believe it I was going look I
think the thing you and I will both
agree with because I know your family
well enough to know this we are
disproportionally you started your I'm
the product of two wonderful parents is
your opening line mm-hmm everybody on my
team you're watching I'm sure took note
of that because that's all I talk about
like I'm the product of my parents in I
don't think the American Dream I think
you know was we're kids we're told about
this America dream and I think people
think it's you come here and you live it
I don't think that's what it is I think
the American Dream is you come here and
you have to give your kids an
opportunity to live it I mean your
parents came here you're living the
American dream my parents came here I'm
living the American dream and that is a
reflection of the sacrifices made by
them to give us that opportunity
grandparents so it gets so intense look
I think where you're going really
matters which is literally I genuinely
believe this it's an interesting
conversation for me the biggest thing
though is I just don't think anything I
did yesterday matters anymore
I really am big on you're only as good
as your last at-bat and I'm glad that I
have some sort of resume but like if I
start [ __ ] up tomorrow it gets washed
ok so this is where it's gonna get fun
for people because I'm gonna push you on
that good I think we're we're always
gonna end up as agreeing but I just want
to push you on that so I agree with you
especially in this world that the
judgment on us is you're only as good as
your last at-bat and I think to remain
successful you have to have a little bit
you have to have that mentality
otherwise you get complacent and
complacency kills ya but the other side
of that is if you're constantly trying
to outdo and outdo and outdo yourself
and you don't acknowledge yesterday you
can go into a very very dark place
and feel like you're not enough and it's
interesting you use this is gonna be
super you're right this is gonna be fun
I don't know if I've ever thought about
outdoing myself I think I just loved it
so much that I want to be able to have
the permission to continue to play
you're a very unique soul and I think
the problem that's the truth because you
and you know we can get into whether you
deal with the pressure I don't know but
I think a lot of people I've met they
get into this place even with gang ups
all right I remember when I did that
Here I am I'm taking this guy who is my
brother now me and it means I have this
thing we joke around we actually say
this to each other instead of saying I
love you we say love you [ __ ] you like
that's like a joke it's a joke between
us but where is he living right now he
lives in Korea and he goes back and
forth to Beijing and he does a bunch of
stuff between the two and but sighs
great but the difference is it's like
psy was like I have to do it again I
have to do it again people were like oh
you guys are you know that was was good
but like can you do it again and
actually gentleman went number three
which was the next one right but the
funny thing is I never saw out to do it
again I had a slightly overweight Korean
man dancing and singing in Korean fully
in Korean and he's in his 40s and he's
coming to the United States I wanted to
get that to be number one the United
States and around the world we did that
it stayed there for multiple weeks that
was the impossible and that's what
people do that you achieved the
impossible and they go oh that was cool
but can you do this and I think if you
start to get in that mold of the
expectations of others and what they
want you missed the point that you
already achieved greatness I understand
you have to live in that too so I
understand what you're saying I think
the problem with me and Gary is we
always say the same thing but we say it
in completely different ways I think
there's you know I only think I admire
you so much because of our similarities
because I love myself so much I really
you know look we play you play a large
part and how I got back in shape though
I actually wanted to give you love to
that because I'm gonna live years longer
for my boys and my daughter because of
you because I watched Gary hire a
trainer 24/7 and I was like you know
what I'm in a place financially where I
can do that and make so much and I need
to kick-start myself so I hired a
trainer to stay with me for 30 straight
days day in and day out there was some
photo you posted on
Instagram where I was like [ __ ] like you
got into shape quickly and like like
when you do the right things but man you
had some real [ __ ] muscles in one
photos I you know what I got herbs DNA
yeah I got my dad is 650 64 has a 6-pack
he's like 200 pounds 6 foot 2 he's a big
dude and I got his DNA so I was able to
like my friend Eugene who I've Rumble
with he was giving me [ __ ] he was like I
work out like you why is this not
happening and I was like you know I have
friends who it doesn't happen for me the
way I see you guys do you know you guys
went into a pretty significant
partnership right because yeah Rumble
he's really I like him a lot
he's a great guy and I'm really excited
for what we do you know him in the catch
days it even be about the promoter days
yeah so you've known him a long time and
June scooter what is it what is it let
me go go completely left field on the
back of that Eugene comment you so you
and I are different in one way you have
been in the seat you've grown up in the
scene and grew in the scene meaning I
did something very weird I literally
worked in a liquor store in New Jersey
never went to Manhattan LA Atlanta
anywhere literally for 14 until I was
like 34 35 years old I've been
fascinated with I love but I keep
bringing up these throwback you know
kind of things because much like Eugene
as well I I was like oh not that I envy
I was like it would have been cool to
come up with all these people and like
see everybody like I came out of left
field kind of in a lot of ways into it
what does it feel like to how do you
look at things like Eugene and others
when you see a lot of people that you
came up with some accelerated some fell
off some did better than you thought in
your own like fun game like what does it
feel like to be part of a scene in
culture for two decades but still be so
young where you know there's another
three four or five chapters I'm sure you
look at some of your friends who were 38
and say wow she's gonna be the Governor
of California one day that one's gonna
be the this like how does it feel to be
part of the zeitgeist that's the way I
would put it um look it's cool because
you know there's history with certain
people and you're rooting for each other
and janna come up and you know there's
there is a respect because you know they
grind it you know that they grind it and
you know that's what I like and you know
the mentality like Eugene is like
me has never been someone to party at
his own party he was he was a worker
from day one and you know a Russian
immigrant who like you know made it
happen and came to the city and saw the
opportunity and grinded it out but he
was like you know hi or some like that
no he was just coming into the city but
do you know where he grew up around here
and then um and and you know I think for
me that's really great but at the same
time I also I also get upset when I see
certain people from that scene who they
find resentment in that you know and and
I just I cuz they didn't make it as big
and they were sometimes it's they were
ahead and they make as big other times
they are making it big but they have the
they made the mistake of thinking that
and I and I see with people I've known
see people I don't know they make the
mistake of thinking success is some kind
of zero-sum game yeah I'm blown away by
people's inability to understand the
abundance yeah like I just I'm shocked
by that well I've never understood it
because I I it's not practice it's not
practical and I think the way I figured
out how to explain it makes it easier
for people to understand because we grow
up in a world where we think that if if
I'm winning someone else should be
losing or if I'm losing someone else is
winning and that's why people get into
that mode and what I like to explain is
I call it the vacation theory where if
I'm successful and none of my friends
are successful I have to pay for them to
go on vacation no one I don't want to
pay for your vacation my goal in life is
to have all of my friends become
successful so that they also can pay for
the nice vacation and it isn't all on me
financially so if you think of it that
way you know because I think a lot of
people they kind of looking into it like
I want to be the one who makes it no you
want everyone to make it and the other
thing I'll say is whenever I talk to
powerful people and I had the pleasure
day of sitting with a mentor of mine
today who's had an incredible career
he's one of my favorite people in the
world and when he talks about other
super powerful people he talks about 30
40 50 years of history and when I think
the beautiful part about that is people
make this this idea that I got to get to
this person you know they think they got
to get to you they think they got to get
to me
you want to know who you got to get to
they're sitting next to you in the
living room dreaming
like you you know they are the they are
your peers if they have you come up
anyone is powerful their network is more
powerful than their money they can say
oh who do you need I've known him for 20
years let me make a phone call it's
coming up that grind me and Eugene we
went into this business together because
we knew each other from the grind yeah
of course you know I can call you know
when I needed Ludacris on baby back in
the day for Justin's first single that
would give him some credibility it was
because Ludacris and I came up with
throw them bows in a nightclub you know
so for me it's not about the person you
aspire to know you should go to them for
stories you know get some wisdom but if
you want to know who you need to network
with network with your peers and help
each other rise up and that's where
power comes from is a question what do
you think you're dramatically better at
like as a dude as a human what do you
think you're way better at today than
even just five years ago like watching
the Jets loose much better at it now
that I was super interesting about my I
don't even know why I'm intuitively
asking this because again listen we're
so busy we don't get to spend that much
time together I think I know the answer
you know the answer I know the answer
because I had to go to a very dark place
to find it tell me cuz I'm really
curious I so you know a lot lot about me
and my family so two years ago I lost
one of the most important people in my
life which was my grandmother and she
was one of the most special human beings
anyone's ever met and everyone who knew
her loved her and she was out Schwitzer
lacoste survivor so she saw the worst of
humanity but literally was it the light
in every room she went into and everyone
called her mom when she passed away my
brother 11 hours later had twins and
nine days later I had my second son so
now I got a wife with a 20-month
21 month old baby and a newborn she's
breastfeeding
I got a dad who's broken because both
his parents are gone and I'm trying to
be the rock for the whole family
and I didn't have time for grieving so I
went into you know I started going into
a depression which I wasn't used to you
know I've gone to different dark places
in the past but I couldn't shake this
one I couldn't sleep it off I couldn't
you know I couldn't get away from it and
I started to get
even more depressed because no one was
asking me if I was okay because I've
been the rock for all of my friends and
my family my entire life I'm always okay
I'm always the mature one you know I
have fun I'll go crazy but I was always
the one that you didn't have to worry
about and I'm always the one who goes
and fixes everyone else's problem and
finally a friend of mine I opened up to
and he said you need to talk to your
wife about it too and I went and talked
to my wife and I expected her to be like
baby we'd get through anything like and
instead she looked at me and she goes
you can always talk to me about anything
I love you but this is your fault yeah
you made the bed and I said well that
person in my life and I said what are
you talking about she goes you always
fix everyone else's problems but you
don't stay long enough to let them know
your insecurities your vulnerabilities
and who you are so you think you're
connected to all these people but they
don't feel connected to you they just
trust you can help them out yeah and I
decided as a New Year's resolution then
I would take time to engage and show
people who I was so that they could be
there for me in dark times it's you know
and and I am much better about that now
taking time out of my busy schedule to
say stop and speak to people and engage
with them and let them know that I've
been through those moments and my life
is more fulfilling now I have more
genuine friendships now that I didn't
even know weren't genuine and you know
that's actually why I even take the time
to do stuff like this because I want to
get that message out there I want people
to know vulnerability is strength yeah
you know I think a lot of people they
think they got to be so tough all the
time because it's weak if you show you
scare you know what's funny and that's
not weakness
did you think it was weakness or I'm
asking you this because this is where we
have a huge similarity for me it comes
so natural to help people yeah
no 100% oh I have so much optimism and
happiness and emotional strength that
whether it's a subconscious guilt
whether it's just appeases me whether
it's control like I know I do a lot of
things emotionally because it's the
leverage yeah I can feel it in me if I'm
self evaluating like it's there's a an
abundance of emotional strength that we
get from our parents a hundred thousand
percent whatever so I think the reason I
do it is because I have it to give and
when I'm surrounded by family members
businesspeople friends acquaintances
like I'm like I want to be there I want
to do it like Boyd's in the room right
now like I had so much fun on a late
Friday night calling him
11:30 p.m. and giving him a piece of
advice like that made me happy because I
had it to give but to your point like
there's no question like in the back of
my mind see it's funny that you gave
that answer I had the great misfortune
of losing all my grandparents except for
one before I was born so basically the
only [ __ ] thing I give a [ __ ] about
is like 11 or 12 people and as long as
they're healthy and here I'm good it's
interesting I have still I'm 42 years
old soon to be 43
I'm widely aware that in my uniqueness
of always being happy that the Domino
that's most vulnerable is something
happening to one of those eight or nine
10 people and I sit here at 43 and I'm
like for all the Who I am and I'm a wild
character and I'm a unique dude I'm like
yeah but guess what the Kryptonite
hasn't happened my mom isn't termini
terminally ill like my dog I mean you
know I've kids I mean the kids one if
you want to talk about like when you're
when you're a family guy or gal you
always talk about like the greatest
especially they can our culture I think
the greatest fear ever is like losing a
child like I couldn't even like yeah you
want to talk about knocking a wuss like
like I'm just like well that put me into
like am I gonna be like Luke Skywalker
and like the new movies and go into a
cave forever probably because I don't
think that wouldn't be inappropriate I'm
like that's you know so guys wanted yeah
what test this guy and I don't know
what's gonna happen he called you the
night 11:30 and be honest yeah be honest
and we will be avoid he obviously knows
you and can help you out but do you
honestly feel you know him and it and
why
[Music]
and but as he opened up to you about his
fears and stuff so my thing is I thought
my friends would say yeah I know but
when I needed help they didn't even know
that was something that was that mean
actually my question is super fun it's a
super interesting content did you even
know what it felt like
like did like it's cool like I could
tell Boyd like for example like and Boyd
might be a little the only thing I ever
talked about from a fear standpoint is
losing or the health and well-being of
everyone else do you think that you
would have even known that you were
capable of going to that place
consistently it's funny you said
something dude I'm so weirded out by
some of our like again I think I want
the audience to know this scoot and I
have had this incredibly interesting
relationship I compared it in a funny
way I've never said this to them of like
relationships I have with my family
members who I take most for granted
because we're almost playing on the same
mental wavelength like you would
probably be stunned how little times
scooter and I've actually cemented
together over the last decade cuz it's
just the way we roll but there is this
deep pinch of the fact that you said
sleep it off it is insane to me that
basically when the worst business things
or life things that have happened to me
outside which I would demonize shut this
off the only way to sleep but I just go
to sleep and the next morning I'm like
let's win like I mean like I remember
when I lost texts there's a business
thing we lost the ability to ship to
Texas which was crippling for Wine
Library and we were the only company
that was picked on by FedEx to not shift
to Texas and was a lot of it was four
million dollars with a small business
and like literally was like this is
dangerous [ __ ] I went home at 3:30 in
the afternoon went to sleep woke up the
next day and just started chopping wood
and like fixed it that's why I am I and
I kind of picked up on that because it
was very subtle the way you said it
so I understand what I don't know if let
me ask you a question
had you ever been able to sustain being
depressed or upset not like how long
prior to tomorrow my grandmother yep our
tomorrow right oh ma like there maybe a
couple days again in your own head stuff
like that
to me I've never been able to be in a
full 24 hour cycle of true depressed
like no hundred percent like it kind of
goes back and forth when that happened
it went really really bad and what was
shocking wasn't the depression what was
shocking was he says he knows you
but because he's never seen you like
that the shocking part was that people
didn't know to ask me if I was okay they
didn't know to say they didn't even
comprehend the idea that I could be
broken I get it man brother and when I
admitted that I had to ask myself why is
that and that was on me that's what my
wife told me she didn't express my fears
I didn't express my vulnerabilities they
didn't know what to look for they didn't
know to be there and I feel like a lot
of people like I was like well why of
course they should know like I've been
so I've been in really important moments
in these people's lives like I've been
there for so many different people but I
realized I never took the time to say
because I'm like you I'm energy I'm gone
I'm this that I fixed it time to go back
next thing you know Superman there I can
hear everything going on let's go
and omnipresent yeah and and the bottom
line is what I had to teach myself which
I'm better at going back to your
original question is to say yes I could
do 40 more things today but I'm not I'm
gonna stay right here and I'm gonna get
deep with this person and I'm going to
engage in a way I normally don't do
interesting I fully understand and that
is something that has made me happier
because it actually hasn't slowed down
any of my success it hasn't slowed down
any of my progress and what it is done
is made me go with more joy into the
next day more ready to fight because I
feel like I had a genuine moment that
day that I didn't realize I was missing
to you two or three years before because
the speed in which you're going II just
it's it's a with game not a depth game
yeah yeah man I super get it I super
understood that and you're happy with
some questions I'm sure people want to
do some questions let's let's do a quick
question we'll keep bouncing because I
have some other contemporary couette
we've gone deep here a little bit which
I appreciate
no it's super interesting I super get it
it's funny I'm sitting here a lot of the
vulnerabilities of diet that I've
created in the two companies that I've
run Wine Library and Vayner the
vulnerabilities are I created
entitlement because I put so much on me
like I have the same thing my staff is
about to hear this so they're gonna
never play ping pong yet but I've been
getting very frustrated we have a very
we have a ping pong table in the middle
of you know the office and I keep seeing
all the young people like playing ping
pong and I'm like what the fake you know
how are you able to play ping pong if
I'm killing myself and you know I always
had
this rule where I was like if you can't
say you work harder than me you can't
complain and no one ever [ __ ]
complaints except Allison who probably
the only person works harder than me
she's been with me for a decade and I
mean Allison had a child and was on
email two hours later that's like and I
was like Allison get off email she's
goes it's boring here like she's an
animal but um but you know i just i
can't understand especially when you're
that age why you want to grind 24/7 max
Maxon yeah yeah back to work Gary
Maxon works too brother Max and you're
on with us Scooter Braun how are you oh
my god how are you good what's your
question yeah I was coming with a
question my brother he's an EDM producer
been doing it for about four or five
years and I help them sometimes and my
question is is that because of our local
shows you look down New Mexico and I
live in Vermont so we do mostly FaceTime
but Max and I'm just very excited about
this like the fact that you're in
Vermont and he's a New Mexico is just
the greatest part of this story because
I don't know how many people have the
Mexico New Mexico Vermont relationship I
think it's rare I think there's a very
small amount of people that the
connection is Vermont and New Mexico and
I think you need to think about how rare
that is and maybe monetize it it's a
rare combo sorry yeah so he does a lot
of local so he has SoundCloud so I guess
my thought is is that obviously he'll
send out his on two different
independent labels and he's had some
singles with it for like one-time
releases what some quotes advice maybe
you would offer scooter or carry on one
he can maybe do to get attention for a
different a in our contacts or people I
labels beyond like social media I mean
Sophie is very important I know there
some other ideas the maxim real quick
before scooter answers is the goal to
get signed like what's the I think the
goal is the most important question yeah
definitely the goal with you to get
signed um he's a senior at college now
and he has a friend than doing it with
him since high school he's a junior
I know he's working contacts he's
studying abroad and Amsterdam so he's
been working with different leads in
there
okay um um I'm ready I'm ready to answer
buddy okay
yeah I disagree with your goal and it's
okay it's and it's against against you
know me being able to sign artists but I
just think you know with this equalizer
we call the Internet and the fact that
you now have Spotify saying they'll do
direct deals with artists and you know
we have this platform especially in a
genre like EDM where albums are very
insignificant and it's all about singles
and mostly touring you know I don't know
why you would want to get signed I think
you know what you should be doing is
focusing on building a fanbase not
worrying about getting to an executive
and you know pushing out the music
through SoundCloud pushing the music you
know as far as you possibly can and
building up a base building up a proper
brand for yourself and let the labels
chase you let the ANR's chase you you
shouldn't be chasing them especially in
a time where it's never been more
advantageous to be independent with the
resources at your fingertips
I just think you guys are focused on the
wrong thing and that's probably why you
haven't found success yet I think once
you sort of all right
no I just think once you focus on
building the brand properly and just
getting to the consumer and getting to
the fans I think you'll start to see
success coming your way and not worrying
about how do we get the attention of
some ANR okay you go authoritative you
build it go calm okay I mean these guys
are all scared trying to hold on to
their jobs and they're not interested in
taking risks like they used to they're
just trying to chase the momentum so the
other thing is I think once you get the
momentum you won't be calling Gary Vee
or myself back and saying hey what deal
do we take you'll be saying I don't
really want to take a deal I like my
economics better now by my own yeah no I
agree that Mac said I want to paint a
picture for you you literally just
called and said yo how what kind of you
know VHS video store should I open up
like I want to build the next
blockbuster literally in the face of
Netflix and Hulu and Amazon Prime and
the golden Arab OTT that is literally no
joke in my opinion what it's like to be
thinking about I disproportionally am
passionate about getting signed in the
moment of the destroyed
we would rather uh you know you have
your brother song be distributed on in
the background of a vlogger that's
crushing YouTube right now then you
getting discovered I do this to just
tell you I think a lot of the artists
eejit they want to get to me right
because of my career I would even say it
37 I'm afraid I'm becoming a dinosaur
like uh you know this technology is
disrupted music so many times and the
resources are so there I got kids now I
got you know a hundred different
businesses you know the way I built an
artist was because that artist was 24/7
my sole purpose and I think that the
resources I have now can take an artist
from stage a2g you know will skip all
the other letters because I have the
network but I can't do it without
someone getting to step a and you know
step a is is is really breaking it
themselves and having that passion and
if you guys are talking about this and
you're calling in from Vermont when he's
in New Mexico it means that you got a
lot of passion for your brother and I
would use that passion because you don't
have to be next to him I mean when I was
doing Justin he was in Canada half the
time and I was doing it from Atlanta I
mean the resources the resources are
there for you give it to the people
build it with them and then you'll be
having a very very different discussion
the next time you call Max and listen
I'm telling you this and it's gonna help
a lot of people the biggest
vulnerability I see across the board in
everything in culture business life is
people are putting something on a
pedestal that was yesterday without
understanding what's gonna happen
tomorrow
this has happened already the leverage
has swung to the artist because
distribution is controlled by the
internet scooters giving you tremendous
advice in lieu of what he actually does
for a living in the same way that I tell
big brands every day don't hire agencies
even though that's what I do for a
living like and the reason we're doing
that is because first we create other
opportunities for ourselves because
we're always hedging against the
vulnerability of our current state but
second because being historically
correct is always going to be the value
prop there is absolutely no reason to
pander to getting signed you need to get
the audience to love you you need to get
the music distributed out there
and by the way if this was 20 30 years
ago you'd be saying how do I get it
distributed I'm pretty sure you know how
to do that on a worldwide yeah no that's
definitely you know that's definitely
something we do yeah that's some good
yarn on Spotify sry like fifty thousand
play no progress the answer is more
right like the thing I tell it boy
having Boyd in the room I meet with a
lot of emerging hip-hop artists cuz I
like it boy likes that it's fun but I
always tell them more [ __ ] music
please like like you're one [ __ ] song
away like the preciousness do you
whatever producing God's good here's
what I'll say awesome Gary yeah and that
was one of the early ones right and like
they just I just don't understand how
people don't understand
an unbelievable part of this is more I
think it's more nice to think if you're
I think part of your question because I
want to give you a proper answer also
you're saying how do i network with
these people let's talk about who you
should network with you said you okay
great you said you have 50,000 plays on
Spotify figure out who runs
listen figure out who runs playlist on
Spotify for the john urine and do
whatever the [ __ ] takes to get to
that person and make them believe in
what you believe in and that's who you
should be focused on that's who the
labels gonna call focus on that person
okay mark of course it's smart who the
[ __ ] do you think you're taking to
[ __ ] man good luck all right let's go
next wish I bet this exactly the right
like like you know I was working on
something fun I never got to tell you
about it because something happened
nonetheless very simply I knew more
about rap caviar in 48 seconds then you
know coming from zero because it's just
not complicated people I think the thing
that you understand the thing that I
definitely understand it's what Vince
McMahon understands it's what Walt
Disney understands it's like
understanding where the consumers
attention is and how that's controlled
is everything was this Jefferson it's
Gary Vaynerchuk you're on the askgaryvee
show with Scooter Braun Wow great well
listen I could tell in your voice how
pumped I totally get it ever since
this is great for me too uh-huh all
right before you go any further is a
very inside joke for Jets fans
you literally sound like Jeff Fisher
calling the Jets game yesterday which
was pretty classic so nonetheless
Jefferson what's your question
my question is um go on I came from
different country yeah just like you
yeah you know country like Guatemala
very nice keep going okay which by the
way I apologize but I have to say it
what's so amazing about you calling for
Guatemala is we referenced earlier in
this podcast I sit on pencils of
promises board and one of the core
countries that we build schools in is in
Guatemala so big shout-out to pop keep
going yeah thank you so in high school
after graduation I really want to go to
school but after that I saw you know
like teens are changing like social
media so one of your videos popped up
and said that you know get rid of people
that don't really like help you so I did
and now you know I don't get like
invited out to like you know Friday
night bars Saturday night bars and stuff
like that so what do you think you
follow me because um just like you I'm a
big like Family Guy you know okay so my
question is now is how do I find
like-minded people there those friends
dad yep that I can work with yep um so
so let me ask you a question what do you
want to do for a living or what are some
of your interests okay so my dad is a
contractor okay yep so what I so what I
did with him is that we build a LLC
company okay okay so my dream is to
build him his dream house that's amazing
brother you know and you know yeah so
you want to be in the contracting
business or is that just a dream like
what is that what is the goal for you in
building a business like what do you
want to do I know you wanna the the goal
is to build your data house but how do
you want to get there what is the
business you want to create okay so I
thought what we're
really good at and my dad does like a
lot of like custom works and his
customer service is like Oh like I'm
eating like not like any other uh
contract with business there so um I I
want to you know help him become bigger
for having to hire other people and you
want to do that by bringing marketing to
the business or being another pair of
hands that can do crafts how are you
thinking about that so I got into uh
like social media unlike Facebook
advertisement Instagram advertisement
and I I did get some some clients from
there but I want to know how we can find
how I personally can find like like
friends that can push me to be better
you know because I would always like
somebody to like come with me and to
learn more more things but at the end of
the day they always like cancel on me
okay I'm trying to understand the
question so I'm gonna answer a couple
different ways I don't know if it'll be
helpful but I'll try well number one I
can tell you from my party promoter days
90% of the people that were in the club
with me 10 years ago are still there so
you know when you're talking about
Friday night bars and this that and the
other like no no life has been changed
on Friday night drinking you know it
that if you're young and ambitious you
know it's good to live life and have fun
but you know I wouldn't worry about that
as like the letdown and anything that's
gonna stop you
so just disregard that because those
people aren't gonna be grinding like you
as far as like finding like-minded
people I don't know your personality
well enough to see who you're gonna gel
with what I can tell you is I would do
research on larger companies that you
admire in your space you know look at
look at these companies that have taken
find people who took you know
contracting companies and built them
into larger real estate holdings and
people who ended up going from
contracting houses to you know building
out commercial real estate and different
things like there there are people who
literally started off in that business
and then ended up owning you know huge
huge amount of real estate themselves
and building very big businesses and
sometimes they're you know doing that in
different ways so what I would say is
start doing those research find those
people create mentors and they might
introduce you to someone else your age
and say hey someone else called me
there's another like-minded person you
should meet I remember years ago I went
and met someone at a record label and he
said there's someone you should meet and
his name is Adam granite he's a young
guy he's become like a GM over here and
now Adam and I have stayed friends all
this time and Adam is now the new you
know he's one of the top international
guys and universal music and we work
hand in hand and we've had a friendship
since I was 19 years old so are you
looking for these friends because you
because you want to get value out of
them in the business world or because
you want some people to hang out with on
a Saturday night
who who are pushing and I think both
matters I'm just curious what you
looking for yeah because I just want you
know like somebody to be there to like
help me as well but I have any questions
so basically yeah honestly the reason I
asked you and even the way you answered
I was getting that vibe like I'm
wondering if there's a very big
difference between finding mentors and
finding friends who are ambitious I
would say tinder or bumble God but do
you see what I mean like like I think
you might be asking for mentorship not
friendship which is very okay I'm just I
got that so that's what is that true or
not that girl okay so so to me a couple
things and I want to move on you're 18
so the biggest fear I have even in the
series of questions and energy is I
promise you one thing scooter and I will
agree on is patience matters massive run
marathon we ate so much [ __ ] [ __ ]
like I just it's so not frustrating
because I want everybody to win but the
amount of people that are gonna lose
that thought it happened overnight for
us without understanding
the sheer amount of out one thing I also
know about scooter and I'm sure this is
what he was cuz I know this these days
I'm sure this is we it was even more
because we were both younger for that
reason like sheer hours of output I'm
like 84 I mean look I'll speak to that
and you can Gary just trigger something
in me so I still remember vividly going
home in my 20s and my dad saying I want
to talk to you I think that you're you
know working too hard you're missing out
on stuff and I looked at and I said dad
I'm trying to do something no one's ever
done before you know so I'm I'm not in
that mode of joy yet I'm in the mode of
grind and I had to make certain
sacrifices to get to where I was that
being said when Gary was talking I was
also thinking about you know there's
this big misconception about success
because of stories like Gary stories
like mine story like Mark Zuckerberg and
people think it just happens that you
know young age and it goes for you and
your 30s and the truth is the average
entrepreneur doesn't even find the
business that makes them successful till
they're 39 years old and I just read
another article that got put out that
the average entrepreneur who has a
successful business in tech is 47 when
they start so there's this misconception
it's all these young people and it's
just not the truth and don't forget
brother the other thing that I'm scared
shitless of is it's been a decade of
good economy so you've got all these
Instagram entrepreneurs that are gonna
get blown the [ __ ] out when the economy
hits the fan and people are over
leveraged trying to act like tough guys
and gals and they're gonna lose and so
like there's so many layers to this your
biggest advantage is you're 18 bingo
like I'm scared till I'm so curious I
say this a lot scooter and take life
take like hat you have such a great
family thing going on like
professionally would you trade
everything you've got right now to be 18
again that's only what I know I'll give
you 10% just for the sake of this game
you get to take 10% of your knowledge
and you get to be 18 starting from zero
would you take it professionally ok let
me just preface it by saying I would not
trade my life to bring it to 18 ever
because I now know my children exist and
I never notice how I hedged it and your
family life take that I'll move that out
yes yeah I go back of course you would
yeah I go back and this is why all these
18 year olds 22 year olds 24 year olds
I'm like dude I'd kill the game
10% wonder saying sooner 1% kill me you
yeah 1% let me back give me 1% my
metabolism crazy whatever I want ever
listen you need to be patient brother
and you need to bring value to mentors
people cold email and DM scooter and I
24/7 365 and they're offering to take us
out to lunch or drive us from the
airport it's a ludicrous trade
it's like laughable you need to bring
value I talk a lot about people
eventually working for people for free
if I want to be a music mogul I swear
I'll say it this way cuz you got the
team here has made a clip for me to post
on Instagram of where I say eventually
people are gonna pay me two hundred
thousand dollars to work for me and I'm
not posting it because it's too douchey
and it's frame work but I'll say this if
my 19 year old best friend if my best
friend you know one of my best friends
from college already has like an 18 year
old a you know just think they had a
baby early if that kid hit me up right
now and said Gary Vee I'm desperate to
be a music mogul I would literally tell
him to hit up his dad Glenn and pay
scooter to work as an intern for free
for him I'm being discharged you know
it's funny about you saying that it's
and and it's funny that you say that for
two reasons one most no no listen it's
when I said for two reasons one because
I always tell people I meet them I was
like stop worrying about getting a job
create so much value for yourself that
they will not let you go and then number
two just today and I'm not gonna tell
the stories as a personal thing I saw an
opportunity to spend more time with
someone I admire and I know that the
time every time I spend time with them I
get knowledge that makes me better yeah
and I said that I would literally I was
I was like hey I want to pay for this
for us to go just because I knew I was
gonna get more time with that more super
flattering to me when you offered and I
was fighting it because I literally
truly believe every single minute I
spend with someone who gives me that
knowledge is the return is a tenfold
every single time in the same way that
tells so many of you that you need to
find optimism and positivity because
that's a mental framework some is
wisdom some is financial information
cultural information listen to me you
you're looking for Mentors
you need to find people that have done
screw to give you a great variation of
this find other people that did what you
wanted if you want to be a music mogul
you should work for free for Scooter
Braun and beg him and pray and guy who
Siri and Troy cars and all these people
that have done things like it's super
smart to bring value like that's the
person you want to be what you see under
the hood when you're closest to the Sun
is disproportionally valuable it's
disproportionate value cool bro thanks I
mean like that is like I'm so intrigued
by this I don't want to say I mean
either I'm good with that one all right
are we doing another phone call no I
gotta get out of here I got a run to
something I want to do one more carry
okay let's do one more because I feel
like like this next kid I used to like
not be a kid I used to be on you know on
the online and I felt like if I don't
answer that the next kid I miss out I
like the great oh yeah so I feel like
this next kid might be special
I'm just feeling some who was the person
you were looking at on YouTube the
person right before Justin oh he was an
artist he was an object he was an artist
he was an artist that Akon had a key
remember his name Brooke it's Gary
Vaynerchuk you're on the askgaryvee show
with Scooter Braun hi oh my god Brooke
before you do anything you need to
thanks cooter tremendously I'm about to
be late for something he pushed me
because he has that kind of energy you
need to really thanks cooter for this
moment
good thank you so much so my name is
Brooke Johnson and Sonia you have
applied for an internship with your
company for several years now my [ __ ]
life you've got the job it's done you've
got the job Espie projects yours you're
locked in it's done it's not a very I
will cancel my life to make this happen
but you are an intern in 4sp it's done
Brooke I'm telling you it's done good
I'm glad you let's say thank you can
read congratu
Brooklyn scooter so I I throw I went to
LA last week I bought $100 plane ticket
just to go down there because I was I
was like hey I'm gonna get some coffee
with CEOs because no one no one calling
I live in Seattle Washington actually
Puyallup Washington keep going Brooke I
down to LA and I was like I'm gonna get
some coffee with CEOs because nobody
nobody was biting on any of my
applications that I was throwing in Sony
like nation could be nothing
and so I got a few interviews but when I
was down there I got pickpocketed I got
my phone fill in I got in a really bad
car accident I was boned and thrown into
intersection I had the biggest interview
of my life the next day at 9:00 a.m. and
when I who's around
it was adidas do both
I find it anyway so I can't tell you
much it's a big big big job and I so
they interview me blah blah but I got an
email last week they're like hey we're
moving our offices so I was like oh
great
I don't know to do and I want to work in
LA Brooke I planned for you what do you
want to do I want to change the world I
understand that don't bull your [ __ ]
shot not ideology your [ __ ] life into
the wrong direction what kind of job
were you by I'm looking for marketing I
want to inspire people to inspire them
don't give me any more
20:19 horseshit get real practical here
right now this is the moment of your
life you're gonna watch this video every
day for the rest of your life and if you
do one more ideological [ __ ]
theoretical [ __ ] thing here when
he's looking for practicality I'm gonna
punch you in the nose okay Brooke here
here's my question for you you say
marketing what gives you experience in
marketing anything what gives me
experience can you repeat that was on
the resume anything yet or nothing I
have a little bit of marketing
experience I was the president of the
American Marketing Association at my
university I
I successfully got a $7000 through okay
so we're you're finding still here
Brooke I through like I didn't sell
anything I just went to my Zumba class
and hit these women I I got these women
on board with my my ideas and they're
like yeah well I'll give you some money
and so I walked out of the YMCA one day
with a thousand dollars and it's things
like that that is my passion for you
just out of curiosity
give me your background your parents
like what did they do my mom's a single
mom she like my dad's completely out of
the picture so Brooke let me get this
straight you're a young lady who I
assume is a single mom like your you got
student loans yes so you got you got
student loans you're grinding you're
going to school you're making things
happen you have a dream of marketing you
by $100 plane ticket in just show up in
LA somehow you got an interview they've
decided to move on all the other people
wouldn't meet with you you got
pickpocket everything else and and then
how did you find out about this tonight
you were just watching Gary's Instagram
yeah one of my friends told me I needed
assault Gary because he was like hey
forget your header your button figure it
out Brooke here's my thing right you you
okay so I want to explain what happened
you Gary needs to go and Gary we just
did a call with a guy and I just said
look my whole life experience it's
always been that last one when I'm about
to leave like answer one more that
something very special happens so we
decided you were the one special I said
Gary one more so that's why he was
saying everything else so so what I'm
saying to you is I get a lot of trouble
with my staff when I meet people in the
street and they ask for an internship
and I say yes I have literally been
super pissed with me right now because I
just did it you know listen I am
actually told I'm not allowed to do that
anymore by my own company because I gave
you so much trouble forgiving rantin and
usually they turn out to not always yeah
they're only [ __ ] they're always
generous but no I usually always [ __ ]
but it worked out a couple times and one
time [ __ ] nets out and guess what
that's why scooter and I have [ __ ]
companies not the [ __ ] henchmen here
in the corner okay so so here's what I'm
gonna say to you Brooke um I
when you graduate I already did roll
scooter okay and you and you want to
work for free you said you just wanted
the internship
well minimum wage gonna be terrible I
will work for free I'm I'm planning on
moving down to Los Angeles within the
week regardless of if I get a job or not
and well money to live how you gonna
afford to live in LA I have a cousin who
told me that I can rent room for 350 and
roast awesome yeah so in San Clarita and
sighs I know okay I'll take that up I
don't know I don't know what Brooke
here's what we're gonna do I'm gonna get
your information I'm breaking my rule
this is not for any kid watching him you
meet me in the street I'm not breaking
my rule again don't get it never
happening again okay but what I'm gonna
tell you is I followed like the universe
has fixed my life plenty of times I was
telling Gary earlier like when I don't
really know sometimes it shows it for me
you need a break and I think sometimes
in life I was talking to Gary Brooks
start [ __ ] crying Brooke I won't
explain this I was talking I was talking
to Gary about luck earlier and what I
mean by that is and I never got to
explain it I have friends who I know are
as smart as me and have worked as hard
as me and have not had the success in
life because along the way did you think
get the breaks and I always tell them
keep going the breaks are waiting for
you the breaks are waiting for you
sometimes it happens earlier in life I
got lucky it happened early on and
sometimes that happens later in life and
sometimes it happens on the askgaryvee
show
and I think tonight happened on the
askgaryvee show so I don't know what it
will turn into but you deserve a break
so I don't I'm not giving you a job yet
but I'm gonna give you the internship
and what I'm gonna do is I'm gonna pay
you minimum wage to Brooke but unlike
the other interns I'm gonna actually
make sure that like you and I you know
that I put you in a couple projects you
know to make sure that I see what you
can do on the marketing side and that's
why we did even better it gets way
better because I'm not letting [ __ ]
scooter here I'll Oprah me so on top of
that because you want to do marketing
I'm flying you I'm paying for all this
[ __ ] I'm flying you to New York I'm
putting you up in a hotel for a week and
or at the ROC's house I haven't figured
it out yet and you're gonna work here at
Vayner for a week
you're gonna work with my team for a
week we're gonna give you all the secret
sauce so that when you go back to
scooters land you're not just doing some
YMCA hustle you're doing 20 19 perfect
marketing you're coming here and we're
gonna teach you as much as we can in a
week you're gonna work 19 hours a day
like our crew does then you're gonna go
back to scooters world and eventually be
the CMO of [ __ ] Scooter Braun
projects so Brooke we're gonna figure
this out the other thing would be one
thing I want you to promise me though if
we do this you got to only promise me
one thing I'm all yours okay I I just
want you to call your mom when you're
done and thank her because I I'm ready
to pitch with two parents and it's hard
already and the fact that your mom has
been a single mom and raised someone
with this an ambition that's a beautiful
thing and she probably put a lot of
sacrifices and you don't even know I
just want you to call her and say thank
you I caught a break tonight
I don't know if it'll turn into but I'm
glad I could hear you need a break so
you got your great tonight
and Brooke and I got one request are you
a Hawks fan well I know you guys got
fans yeah cohosh okay you now have to
become a New York Jets family right now
like there's nothing else to say like
Russell is a great guy like Pete Carroll
for Jets coach but right here right now
you have to tell the world you are now
in New York Jeff damnation look you guys
change your I can [ __ ] do anything
with myself you know I don't want you to
answer this Berg I need to say something
now I really like you the problem with
football fans and this is why is it Jets
fan I respect Eagles fans other people
yeah is that there are all these people
that are only fans when they're winning
they're here where the fans Jets fans
yeah I'm here about Joey Lee Amith our
entire loves were real fans yes like the
fact that she just got this and still
had the guts that was good
I'm staying a Seahawks fan yeah Brooke I
[ __ ] with you Brooke on the other hand I
don't so I'm taking everything I'm
taking everything I offered off the
table no New York no d-roc house no
flight here you have to go straight to
bucket the scooters world and you can
knock on YMCA doors and [ __ ] sell
some albums I define
I'll fly into your office don't worry
I'll figure out a way I'm kidding
listen I'm super excited he's gonna send
you a message right now to your Facebook
with my email we'll get we'll get set up
will forward it to monitors land you
want to do we care she's gonna come here
for a week we're gonna train her to be
yeah we'll put her up for a week and
train her and then we'll send her back
to you with more talent then I'm gonna
pay for the flight to LA from there and
then you move into your cousins and
we'll start the internship oh my god
Brooke
copy and Brooke yeah I'm gonna buy you
$4,000 car what are you aww you really
oughta be good serious she can't get to
your [ __ ] office without a car I
don't know what 4,000 gets you in car
were older you want to say my split it
done Brooke we're buying you 4,000 our
car my office is gonna be really pissed
that I'm just giving out cars and
they've been working what the [ __ ]
Brooke I'm gonna hang up now because I'm
about to buy you a house congratulations
Brooke [ __ ] scooter made your life by
the way it's also ruber and lift you
know it yeah I know but let's get her I
want her to drive a 4000 our car because
there's a little bit of that ghetto
magic that I'm interested in I want this
Russell Drive do you get to choose it
yeah it's green but not that teal
[ __ ] up in Seattle it's hunter green
brick with my new [ __ ] car you've got
a job you work for scooter like you're
[ __ ] coming getting [ __ ] like IP
from Vayner like shit's good tonight
we're throwing up my old crying awesome
we love you Brooke scooter you're
amazing see Yeah right that's what we do
the extra funds I get it I'm not even
doing a question today that was the
[ __ ] ending of the day I love you
brother
- always I'll see you soon that was
amazing see you bye
[Music]